this is everything's Jake aka Futurama
reunion um how many Futurama voice
actors aren't you probably just two but
most of it but like they were all
Futurama voices yeah you know I mean
it's like a Billy West has done a lot of
different voices but it's like every one
of those characters was a Futurama
Karen's like Farnsworth and I think Zach
Brannigan at Brannigan is is him two
fries in there and they're like trans
McNeil I I'd be amazed if it wasn't
those two we can't watch the credits on
this but it's like it's it's gotta be
those two um so this is a pretty again a
pretty fun concept
I guess Magic Man just comes in as a fly
I think we're both thinking on your
ghostly Magic Man was it was like a
Turner there's something like that that
was it oh that's still probably like my
favorite introduction of any chair so in
Jackson was something he says some sort
of nonsense about like waffles pink
yellow or something I uh won the lot
what's like when the waffle molds eat
the yellow we're not gonna get everybody
oh you do okay I'm sure like people
gonna correct us if we got that wrong
well cuz I found it weird when he looked
the only thing that was out of color was
the waffle Wow when he was looking like
in the food yeah we took the entire
thing everything was yellow except for
that waffle
what color was that there's like a white
huh I missed that it's interesting yeah
so I thought there's gonna be more to it
or and then again maybe the way you get
to it I don't know maybe like waffle is
what he was thinking about either yeah I
don't know another weird one
yeah so so injection with something
where his face sinks into his Bell
pretty much and he just somehow creates
this own world made of him and he's a
little visitor in it and everything is
somehow connected to him like whenever
he walks his foot some you know is still
part of him so he can't like jump up or
anything like that he can't leave
himself and eventually his a friend of
his that he just claims like you know
it's been so long it's like I've never
met you but there's still only five
bucks and everything is acts like
they've known each other for a while
yeah has that weird flapping thing and
goes to all the various Billy West
scientist and they say that if he leaves
it like destroyed their civilization
because they'll need all of the town to
go back to normal but he needs me then
he's hungry so the friend breaks him out
says you no longer owe me five bucks and
then he grows up for lack of a better
term and gets a snack and feels remorse
that he pretty much destroyed an entire
civilization oh that's right goosey so
you know getting his neck who's getting
a snack and I forgot to mention that
whatever grandpa Fraggle went into outer
space that's the first thing I thought
of what he's like he travels and he sees
like the movie playing instead of you
know vodka you buy cloth I'm seeing the
gloves and Finn comes up I'm assuming
that was like a Cthulhu reference or so
my god I thought you'd be beautiful
melts so a great concept and done well I
you know something about this one and
the last one I'll admit like while I
like them fine they seem a little slower
did you get that at all mmm-hmm I I
guess I always remember Adventure Time
just like the lines and the action
everything just had this really quick
speed where even if it was slowly was so
bizarrely slow that Kant kept you on
your toes and with these last two it's
like they're they're still strange you
know and enjoyably odd but they felt the
pacing everything just felt a
slower like the the only example I can
think of it's really nitpicky don't get
me wrong but the best thing I can think
of it's when the one scientist is
talking about like how if Jake goes back
he will like destroy us all or something
like that I mean he you know it
Bob's with boys he's starting to talk
and then he takes a second to sorta get
up and stand up and he keeps talking I
think of myself I wouldn't normally see
that adventure tonight you would keep
talking while standing up because
everything's so quick and fast now it's
the same thing I start out from the fly
episode where everything was like
they're animating the motion of somebody
getting up and doing something or
walking or something and they're usually
like if they're gonna do it they serve
play it like a joke like isn't it funny
how long this is taking or how awkward
that beep was hmm I don't I could just
be really nitpicky I don't know um but
yeah that or maybe I've just been away
from it so long I've been watching like
other fast shows or something but uh I
don't know I'm go ahead let me know if
anyone else has picked up on that cuz
I'm wondering if it's just me it could
very well just be me and because I've
been away from for for so long so what
about you what do you think I when we
were first watching in everything and
the goose came up it was I'm like oh my
god I know that and you just yell up
Billy West and I'm like oh my God thank
you so much I've driven me nuts but what
I like or I'm curious about is notice
his friend goose his best friend goose
is in the fry voice benders best friend
is best fan the scientist has a farm
worth voice yeah I'm wondering if that
was completely intentional to have them
sound so similar yeah they sounded like
it what he was even trying to do a
different voice yeah that's like I'm
just which we've heard voice actors like
oh I know like Joe DiMaggio honest yeah
like he does not change his voice that
much but he's also not especially
well-known for doing they it's sort of
like getting Harrison Ford for something
you get him to kind of play Harrison
Ford like you know Samuel Jackson yeah
Jackson you know I mean they do variety
sometimes but it's mainly like you're
not looking like oh my god who was that
actor he just disappeared in a role it's
like now you know you're watching
Jackson yeah or whoever um but yeah
those were just like so on the ball and
then I have just McNeil in there to who
I I could be wrong but may isn't really
sound like trust me if not it's an
amazing trust making impression so uh
that and the when the scientist is gonna
be least gonna leave this little one
comes up words like Oh son and it's it's
I love I'm sorry yeah that was great
yeah we say you you think it's uh no no
it was uh yes son don't go outside dad
and you swear it's gonna be a first you
think maybe kid and then you know son
don't go I like oh it's gonna be the
mother I'm sorry dad and so that was
like a good yeah you know couple
surprises just in that one delivery so I
liked I thought it was fun I want to
know what the hell's up with that
freakin waffle and actually come to
think of it there's the waffle and then
when there's the final shake there's one
guy in the background that's also
discolored hmm yeah yeah I totally
didn't pick up on that I do like how the
sky is like The Truman Show it's kinda
like a wall baby Klein's ios8 myself
well wait how did the clouds flow thing
cuz you know you can't really separate
or flow now that happens I like that
they're all connected and the balloon
comes up and yeah you know the one thing
that I didn't know about did you really
need magic man in the opening yeah I
think we've been fine if he just fell
asleep fell into his stomach and this is
just going on like this maybe this
happens all the time you don't know I
mean did you really feel like give me a
man-to-man to say hey this is why this
is happening or it may be funny ever I
thought it just happened like all the
time I feel like I may be leaning
towards something else plus it's so nice
just to see magic men doing magic many
things yeah it was just like a fly I
really wanted like some other time TIFF
ago so I was really hoping like he runs
into the ghost fly or something but you
know kisi or maybe that's just the idea
like you think at the opening oh it's
gonna be about the fly nope see ya when
he came in the first thing that came to
my mind was the ghost plug yeah but no
this is it's magic it's magic
so um yeah good stuff uh we'll see you
next one